Welcome to another Epic Games Unreal Engine training course.
Today, the focus will be on Control Rig and Procedural Rigging.
We'll be taking a look at what procedural rigging is in Unreal Engine,
and getting a basic understanding of what it means to create a Control Rig procedurally.
We'll then dig into the construction event and some new procedural rigging nodes and functions
that we use to create these Control Rigs.
And then go over a demo of building a simple FK rig procedurally
using two slightly different methods.
And very quickly, this is something you could use in your own project
to create a simple FK rig that you'd be able to share across
all of the skeletons within your project.
We've included the project file so you can follow along as we go through the demo,
so make sure you get that open and we can jump straight in.